komm zum nächsten Tagesordnungspunkt es
geht um die einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht am 15 März
Personal für die Beschäftigten von
Gesundheits- und Pflegeeinrichtungen
eine Corona Impfpflicht also die
sogenannte einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht das Gesetz stößt seit Wochen
auf Kritik im Dezember ist es vom
Bundestag und Bundesrat beschlossen
worden auch mit den Stimmen der Union
allerdings gab es gerade von der Union
da Kritik bei uns Ministerpräsident
hatte erst angekündigt dass ein
Bundesland
mildere Töne auch aus Bayern also die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht ab 15
März soll sie bundesweit gelten die AFD
allerdings steht hier einen Antrag und
sagt diese Impfpflicht soll abgeschafft
werden bevor sie in Kraft tritt
in den letzten zwei Jahren gab es hier
viele Debatten
da standen
besondere Menschen im Mittelpunkt
nämlich Ärzte Arzthelfer Krankenpfleger
Betreuer von Behinderten
Intensivpflege Altenpfleger
Rettungssanitäter und viele andere mehr
und sie standen zu Recht im Fokus der
Debatte hier weil sie in den letzten
zwei Jahren Dinge geleistet haben die
Sie regelmäßig an ihre Grenzen gebracht
hat haben und dafür gebührt ihnen
Respekt
nun aber droht vielen davon der
Jobverlust warum ist das so weil sie vor
mir hier die große Mehrheit des
Deutschen Bundestages im Dezember eine
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht
beschlossen haben was heißt das bis zum
15.03 müssen
Beschäftigte im Gesundheitssektor eine
gültigen Impfschutz nachweisen
andernfalls droht ihnen ein
Beschäftigungsverbot
Lohn Entgeltausfall und sogar die
Kündigung
und wir reden hier nicht von 10 oder 20
000 Betroffenen
5,1 Millionen Beschäftigte arbeiten im
Gesundheitssektor und im Sozialwesen
wenn wir annehmen und das sind die
Zahlen auf die wir unterstützen können
das 10% nicht geimpft sind vermutlich
sind es eher mehr reden wir von 500.000
Beschäftigten die hier von einer
Kündigung betroffen sind
meine Damen und Herren sie beklatschen
hier zwei Jahre lang diese Menschen und
drohen ihn dann am Ende nur weil sie
nicht geimpft sind ihre Existenz
wegzunehmen das ist nicht nur
heuchlerisch das ist niederträchtig
aber es gibt immer noch jemanden der bei
Ihnen einen draufsetzen kann und ich
nehme einfach nur mal den Chef der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit Detlef schäle
der droht dass diejenigen die dann ihren
Job verlieren auch noch eine Sperre beim
Arbeitslosengeld bekommen
hier geht es um die soziale Existenz von
Menschen und ich glaube dass das von
Ihnen hier einfach vergessen wird
und ich sage Ihnen noch was Angst Druck
Zwang Berufsverbote das was wir hier in
den vergangenen zwei Jahren erlebt haben
das ist kein Mittel das sind keine
Mittel demokratischer Herrschaft
demokratischer Regierung das sind Mittel
autoritärer Herrschaft und diese
autoritäre Herrschaft werden wir hier in
diesem Land immer bekämpfen jedenfalls
von dieser Seite aus
massive Auswirkungen auf den
Gesundheitssektor haben die Caritas hat
ja nicht nur mich angeschrieben sondern
auch sie größter Bundesverband in diesem
Bereich und sie sagen in ihrem Schreiben
die Sicherstellung der Versorgung im
Gesundheits- und Sozialwesen ist
erheblich gefährdet
die Karibik Solidarität schreibt in
einem Schreiben dass sie auch bekommen
haben sie sagen dort es gibt massive
Einschränkung der Versorgungssicherheit
es wird personalverlust geben nicht nur
bei den ungeimpften sondern auch bei den
Geimpften denn wenn die ungeimpft nicht
mehr arbeiten können dann werden die
Arbeitsbedingungen noch schlechter die
Arbeitsbelastung noch höher es werden
noch mehr diese Berufe verlassen sie
werden abwandern in andere Berufe oder
sogar ins Ausland
Anfang der Woche schrieben 450
Feuerwehrleute der Berliner Feuerwehr an
die Senatsverwaltung und ich zitiere die
Impfpflicht in Berlin wird ab dem 16
märz zu einer dramatischen und nicht
beherrschbaren Sicherheitslage führen
das alles ist das Ergebnis ihrer Politik
und diese Leute denken sich das nicht
aus sie haben Angst sie haben Angst dass
sie den Beruf nicht mehr ausüben können
der ihnen wichtig ist
was uns droht wenn dieses Gesetz greift
ist der Zusammenbruch des
Gesundheitssystems das was das
Coronavirus nicht geschafft hat das
schaffen Sie mit einem einzigen Gesetz
und dafür sollten Sie sich schämen
[Applaus]
und habe gefragt wie soll denn der
Fachkräftemangel behoben werden und da
ist doch die Antwort allen Ernstes wir
werden bei der N eine Änderung des
Fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetzes in
Betracht ziehen das ist doch nicht ihr
Ernst die verdrängen hier Leute aus dem
Job und importieren dann Fachkräfte aus
dem Ausland das ist doch keine seriöse
Politik das ist verräterische Politik
meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
da die vier Minuten zu kurz sind komme
ich direkt zum Schluss
wir müssen uns ehrlich machen dieses
Gesetz darf nicht kommen wir können uns
die Auswirkungen dieses Gesetzes nicht
erlauben deutschland braucht keine
Impfpflicht deutschland braucht keine
lockdowns und keine
kontaktbeschränkungen deutschland
braucht seine Grundrechte zurück und vor
allem braucht Deutschland eins und das
ist Freiheit danke schön für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
im Dezember von Bundestag und Bundesrat
beschlossen worden gestern saßen ja
Punkt und wenn dann noch einmal zusammen
zur corona-lage die einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht war dabei ebenfalls noch mal
Thema aber
die Unterländer haben sich sozusagen
darauf verständigt dass es für die
Beschäftigung in der Pflege und
Gesundheitswesen gelten soll und die
Gesundheitsminister sollen dass sie
Umsetzung anbelangt von Bund und Ländern
weiter darauf schauen
sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger ganz
besonders aus meinem Wahlkreis
Ravensburg und aus dem Bodenseekreis
was hier gerade eben vorgetragen und
vorgerechnet wurde muss ich doch
entschieden in den Bereich der Fabel
verweisen
bevor ich zu diesem Antrag komme eine
kleine Anmerkung zu meinem Vorredner und
seiner Fraktion die mir in meiner ersten
Rede hoffentlich gestattet ist
wie kann es sein dass sie sich als
rechtsstaatspartei sehen und dabei den
Rechtsstaat so mit Füßen treten
andauernd tauchen ihre
Fraktionsmitglieder auf dubiosen nicht
angemeldeten verbotenen Demonstrationen
auf sie marschieren dort bewusst auch
mit rechtsextremen auf Teilen deren
Positionen und machen unseren
Polizistinnen und Polizisten das Leben
schwer wie kann es sein dass sie es
nicht schaffen die einfachsten Regeln
für eine gesungene Zusammenarbeit
einzuhalten sie führen sich auf wie
Kleinkinder wenn es darum geht eine
Maske zu tragen obwohl nein selbst
kleine Kinder erkennen den Nutzen der
Maske sie tragen sie mit Stolz weil sie
erkannt haben dass sie damit ihre
Freundinnen und Freunde oder auf ihre
Großeltern schützen
viel hingegen haben es noch nicht einmal
geschafft sich richtig testen zu lassen
um an der Bundesversammlung teilzunehmen
sie gefährden wissentlich und
willentlich die Arbeitsfähigkeit dieses
Hauses
jetzt aber zum Antrag
die blau-braunen von Rechtsaußen würden
am liebsten die beschlossene
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht
abschaffen das ist an sich keine
Neuigkeit und auch nicht weiter
beachtenswert es setzt die Tradition
fort das alles was schlecht ist für die
Gesellschaft gut für die AFD ist
sie da drüben und auf dem Viren Balkon
da oben sie nehmen ohne Rücksicht viele
Tote und langzeitkranke in Kauf
von Krankheit Missgunst und Neid dass
dabei in diesem Antrag auch noch
mehrfach ein rechtspopulistisches
Online-Magazin zitiert wird setzt den
ganzen doch die Krone auf
wenn ich hier sagen würde was ich von
ihnen allen und ihren Anträgen halte
würde ich mir in meiner ersten Rede im
Bundestag direkt meine erste Rüge
anfangen
was ich aber ganz klar sage
wir von der SPD-Fraktion wir stehen zu
dieser einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht
Ausbrüche in Krankenhäusern und
Pflegeheimen haben gezeigt wie drastisch
die Auswirkungen einer ungeimpften oder
nicht genügend geimpften Belegschaft
sind ich sage aber auch dass ich damit
noch nicht ganz glücklich bin denn
diejenigen die seit zwei Jahren unter
teilweise schwierigsten Umständen den
Laden am Laufen gehalten haben
diejenigen die sich um die besonders
schutzbedürftigen gekümmert haben sie
sollen jetzt als einzige
Bevölkerungsgruppe unter die Impfpflicht
fallen da verstehe ich deren Unmut und
genau deshalb ist die Debatte über eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht die wir aktuell
im Parlament führen so unglaublich
wichtig
und genau deshalb setze ich mich dafür
ein dass alle Menschen ab dem 18
Lebensjahr geimpft werden müssen und
genau das müssen wir schnellstmöglich
beschließen denn das würde dafür sorgen
dass wir nicht noch mal Weihnachten
unter pandemiebedingungen feiern müssen
das würde auch diese Ungerechtigkeit
zwischen dem personalent und
Gesundheitseinrichtungen und der übrigen
Bevölkerung beseitigen
wir haben es in dieser Woche nicht
geschafft die Anträge im Plenum zu
behandeln die für die Debatte notwendig
sind ich würde mir wünschen dass das
nicht bis zur nächsten regulären
Sitzungswoche aufgeschoben wird lassen
Sie uns deshalb beherzt vorangehen
einstweilen ist die einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht die zweitbeste Lösung aber
sie ist die richtige und sie ist
unabdingbar ich bin überzeugt dass auch
die Länder diesen ersten Schritt
mitgehen werden und zwar
verantwortungsvoll mitgehen werden und
nun freue ich mich auf die produktive
und hoffentlich auch erfolgreiche
Zusammenarbeit mit allen Abgeordneten
der demokratischen Parteien besonders im
Gesundheitsausschuss vielen Dank
sagt Heike Engelhardt für die
SPD-Fraktion sitzt sie jetzt im
Gesundheitsausschuss als neue
Abgeordnete ihr Wahlkreis ist Ravensburg
in Baden-Württemberg
zum Antrag der afd-fraktion
sie spricht für die cdu/csu-fraktion
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen in den
letzten Wochen habe ich mit vielen
Klinik und einrichtungsleitungen in
meinem Wahlkreis gesprochen
unisono wurde mir gesagt wir stehen
hinter der sektoralen Impfpflicht und
haben mit viel Engagement unsere
Mitarbeitende überzeugt sich impfen zu
lassen aber es gibt nach wie vor
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter die
sich aus unterschiedlichen Gründen nicht
impfen lassen können oder wollen was
machen wir nun mit diesen
hochgeschätzten Leistungsträgern müssen
wir sie kündigen wo sollen wir am
Arbeitsmarkt Ersatz bekommen und wir
können auf keine und keinen verzichten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Ampelkoalition im Dezember letzten
Jahres also vor über zwei Monaten hat
der Deutsche Bundestag das Gesetz zur
sektoralen Impfpflicht beschlossen in
Anbetracht der damaligen Sachlage war es
richtig diese Entscheidung zu treffen
aber Betreiber von Einrichtungen und
auch unsere Unionsfraktion sind davon
ausgegangen dass im Vorfeld des Gesetzes
die Umsetzung bereits mitgedacht wird
und nach Beschluss zügig und ordentlich
an Durchführungsbestimmungen und
Handreichungen gearbeitet wird
damit die Betreiber von Einrichtungen
wissen was zu tun ist wenn Arbeitskräfte
keinen Impfnachweis vorlegen damit Sie
wissen welche Arbeits- und
sozialrechtlichen Folgen auf Sie
zukommen und damit Sie nicht nur einen
Fragen und Antworten Katalog auf einer
Webseite suchen müssen
all diese Fragen wurden bis heute nicht
geklärt sind Zeugnis einer überforderten
Bundesregierung die mit dem Versprechen
angetreten ist alles besser zu machen
und schon jetzt einsehen muss dass sie
dieses Versprechen nicht einhalten kann
und was sind die Folgen die
Beschäftigten die während Corona an ihre
Grenzen gekommen sind und für die wir
geklatscht haben sind total verunsichert
wie es mit ihnen weitergeht Pflegekräfte
die einen anderen Beruf erlernt haben
gehen in diese Berufe zurück andere
weichen auf Berufszweige aus die nicht
der Impfpflicht unterliegen
in meinem Wahlkreis spielt auch die Nähe
zum Schweizer Arbeitsmarkt der eine hohe
Sogwirkung hat eine große Rolle
Mitarbeiter die sich bisher ganz bewusst
für deutsche Arbeitsverhältnisse
entschieden haben gehen in die Schweiz
all diese Menschen werden unserem
Gesundheitssystem fehlen nicht nur
kurzfristig einmal umorientiert wird es
schwierig sein sie wieder
zurückzugewinnen
ja wir haben einen
eklatantenfachkräftemangel im gesundbau
und Gesundheitsbereich und es bedarf
eines dringenden Sofortprogramms mit
intelligenten Maßnahmen um wieder mehr
Menschen für diese Berufe zu gewinnen
unabhängig von Corona und unabhängig von
der sektoralen Impfpflicht denn die
Beschäftigten im Gesundheitsbereich
haben bereits jetzt ein
außerordentliches Maß an
Impfbereitschaft an den Tag gelegt dafür
und für den großen Einsatz in diesen
Zeiten gebührt ihnen großer Dank
sie haben ein Recht darauf dass sie
wissen was auf sie zukommt wenn sie sich
nicht impfen lassen ebenso wie den
einrichtungsleitungen
Handlungsspielräume aufgezeigt werden
müssen und es nicht dem Ermessen aller
Gesundheitsämter im Land zu überlassen
und da gäbe es einige Möglichkeiten aber
es liegt an der Regierung ihre
Hausaufgaben zu machen und zu liefern
machen Sie sich an die Arbeit
[Applaus]
wie viele Pflegekräfte sind eigentlich
geimpft dass es gar nicht so einfach zu
ermitteln ist gar nicht so einfach an
Zahlen zu kommen zum Teil gibt es Zahlen
beispielsweise vom Robert-Koch-Institut
dass sie rund 16.000 Angestellten an
Krankenhäusern betrifft dort gibt es
Zahlen von Mitte November da waren 92%,
die impft bei den Ärzten waren sogar 98%
ähnlich wie bei den niedergelassenen
Medizinern aber insgesamt dass die Lage
der Pflege anbelangt gibt es nicht so
viel belastbare Zahlen
unsere Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu
schützen und eine Überlastung des
Gesundheitswesens zu verhindern und mit
der im Herbst und wintergrasierenden
omikonwelle ist uns das weitgehend
gelungen und die schrecklichen Bilder
der Überlastung von Pflegepersonal aus
den ersten Wellen konnten vermieden
werden
die Infektionszahlen sind nach wie vor
hoch und viele Menschen liegen auch
heute noch auf den Intensivstationen und
das wird auch in den nächsten Wochen so
bleiben
jetzt beginnt aber die Zahl der
Neuinfektionen zu sinken und daher ist
es angemessen und geboten bisher
notwendige Einschränkungen von
Freiheitsrechten ab dem 20 März wieder
zu lockern wie es bunt und Länder
gestern beschlossen haben
von einem freiheitstag zu reden sind wir
allerdings weit entfernt es besteht
leider kein Anlass zur Sorglosigkeit
oder gar Entwarnung
wir sollten uns aus den vergangenen zwei
Jahren wirklich lernen das ist immer
wieder neue Virusvarianten geben kann
die zur Krankheit und Tod führen oder
das Gesundheitswesen überlassen konnten
und der wirksamste Schutz dafür war ist
und bleibt das Impfen
ich kann nur davor warnen dass ich die
Fehler wiederholen von 2021 2020 dass
man die Pandemie für beendet erklärt und
im Herbst mit neuen Varianten in die
nächste Katastrophe läuft mit
Besonderheit und Augenmaß werden wir mit
Corona umgehen können und auch auf
diesem Weg steht vorrangig das Impfen
das Impfen besonders gefährdeter
Menschen von Hochbetagten von Menschen
mit akuten oder chronischen Erkrankungen
von pflegebedürftigen Menschen
sie aber auch Menschen mit Behinderung
wir sind oft besonders gefährdet wenn
sie in Einrichtungen oft eng
Zusammenleben dort ist das Risiko
besonders groß und gerade diese Menschen
haben alle das Recht auf dem besonderen
Schutz durch unsere Gesellschaft
wissenschaftlich belegt ist dass die
data Variante Menschen trotz Impfungen
zwar infizieren kann aber die das Risiko
einer schweren Erkrankung geringer ist
und dass die Übertragung des Virus
deutlich reduziert ist
und daher kommt dem Personal in solchen
Einrichtungen eine besondere
Verantwortung zu denn sie stehen im
engen und intensiven Kontakt mit den
Menschen die auf ihre Hilfe oder Pflege
angewiesen sind und der hat Angehörigen
die sich oft in dieser Pandemie allein
gelassen geführt haben ich rede hier
bewusst nicht von Pflegepersonal dann
ist auch ungeimpfte Chefärzte es gibt
ungeimpftes Betreuungspersonal und
Reinigungskräfte und deshalb ist es
richtig dass die gesamt das gesamte
Personal geimpft sein muss für den
eigenen Schutz aber vor allem für den
Schutz der Menschen die sich ihnen
anvertraut haben und der professionellen
Fachpflege kommt dabei eine
Schlüsselrolle zu
muss endlich in Wert gesetzt werden akut
in dieser pandemiebekämpfung und
grundsätzlich mit dem Auftrag guter
Pflege in einer alternden Gesellschaft
schauen wir in die Nachbarländer überall
wo die Pflege einen wichtigen ein
anerkannte Akteur ist im
Gesundheitswesen steigen die
Pflegekräfte nicht aus und sie sind
haben eine hohe Impfquote und auch dort
ist das Impfen selber nicht der Grund
für den Ausstieg genauso wenig wie das
hier bei uns der Fall ist Pflegekräfte
sind sehr viel schlauer als sie uns hier
weiß machen wollen
und deswegen haben wir in dieser
Regierung beschlossen den Pflegeberuf
attraktiver zu machen unter anderem mit
besserer Bezahlung mit besseren
Arbeitsbedingungen mit verbindlicher
Personalbemessung mit Anspruch auf
familienfreundliche Arbeitszeiten
aber wir werden auch die Fachpflege
aufwerten um halbkundliche Tätigkeiten
sowie neue Berufsbilder in der
Versorgung wie die gemeindepflege mit
der Community heißt das sind die
Herausforderungen die wir haben denn wir
brauchen Pflegefachkräfte die Menschen
in jedem Alter dabei unterstützen
soziale Teilhabe zu realisieren gute
medizinische und pflegerische Leistungen
zu erhalten und zwar völlig unabhängig
davon ob sie in einer Einrichtung leben
oder zu Hause das ist die Aufgabe hoch
professioneller wissenschaftsbasierter
Pflege und dafür setzen wir uns ein und
deswegen fordere ich Sie alle auf hier
gemeinsam dafür beizutragen dass wir die
Menschen in diesen Einrichtungen
schützen und das können wir am besten
indem wir für gute Impfquoten sorgen und
endlich dann uns auch auf den Weg machen
die gute Pflege für alle und für die
nächsten Jahrzehnte zu organisieren
nicht danke Ihnen für die Aufmerksamkeit
hat die europäischen Nachbarn
angesprochen in Italien beispielsweise
ist es so das heißt April seit April
letzten Jahres pflege-ärzte Apotheker
geimpft sein müssen in privaten wie ein
staatlichen Einrichtungen in Frankreich
gibt es sogar Strafen bis hin zum
Gefängnis seit September mussten dort
Pflegekräfte Ärzte sowie beschäftigt den
Krankenhäusern Altersheim zumindestens
eine Impfdosis vorweisen ab Mitte
Oktober den kompletten es Schutz
letzte Woche hatte ich im Vorfeld der
Präsidentenwahl die Ehre für ein
Gespräch mit dem Intensivpfleger Ricardo
lange er war für uns bei der
Bundesversammlung dabei die meisten
kennen Ricardo lange weil er es
insbesondere bei der Pandemie regelmäßig
schafft die prekäre Situation der
Pflegekräfte in die Öffentlichkeit zu
bringen
wie Verdi hat auch eher die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht
kritisiert denn für was müssen
Pflegekräfte eigentlich noch alles
herhalten ich habe zwei Jahre sind sie
der Krankheit ausgesetzt wie niemand
anderes als zu wenig Masken da waren
mussten sie in ständige Gefahr der
Ansteckung Menschenleben retten das
berühmte und beinahe verspottente
klatschen blieb übrig weil die Regierung
nun mit den aufsuchenden Impfkampagnen
versagte sollen sie beim viel zu schnell
aufgesetzten Gesetze Impfpflicht als
Proband innen herhalten und hatten
plötzlich den Stempel der
pandemietreiber ausgerechnet die müsste
man nun zwingen es ist absurd die Linke
verlangte im Dezember
das mit der Verpflichtung wenigstens
eine Prämie verbunden wird das wäre ein
Zeichen gewesen das wäre mal was aber
selbst dieser Antrag wurde vor dem
Koalitionsparteien abgelehnt und bis
heute haben sie das Versprechen einer
Prämie nicht auf die Reihe bekommen die
Versprechen weiter wie wir eben gerade
gehört haben sie bekommen in zwei
Monaten keine Prämie hin aber ziehen in
einer Woche
ist doch wirklich absurd Liebe Koalition
ist doch falsch aber schlimmer geht's
immer der pflegemangel ist ins
Freiheit nun kurzzeitig das Trikot vom
Team Pflege über gestreift und jetzt für
die AFD damit fischen
deswegen
geben Sie solchen instrumentalis
hören sie auf Verdi hören sie auf
Ricardo hören sie auf deine Kollegin und
Kollegen entlasten und entlohnen sie die
Pflegekräfte endlich richtig vielen Dank
hier genau der Sprecher für Krankenhaus
und pflegepolitik der Linksfraktion und
die nächste hier in der Aussprache zum
am Tag der Fraktion der hätte platziert
wird ist Nicole Westig die
pflegepolitische Sprecherin der
Liberalen
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die AFD hat den
Fachkräftemangel in der Pflege entdeckt
und will ihn sogar beheben als
Patentlösung schlägt sie die Abschaffung
der einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht
vor diese Lösung ist ebenso schlicht wie
ambitionslos denn die Impfung ist der
Ausweg aus der Pandemie seit über einem
Jahr können wir uns glücklich schätzen
Impfstoffe gegen covid 19 zu haben viele
einrichtungsleitungen haben sich direkt
auf den Weg gemacht um aufzuklären und
Beratungsgespräche zu führen und für die
Impfung zu werden mit Erfolg denn in
vielen Bundesländern haben wir gute
Impfquoten beim Pflegepersonal
Beschäftigte in Pflege und Medizin
bewegen sich auf dem Boden der
medizinischen Fakten und Fakt ist die
Impfstoffe sind sicher sie schützen
insbesondere vor einem schweren Verlauf
einer kobeterkrankung
hinzu kommt das Besondere Berufsethos
von pflegenden sie übernehmen
grundsätzlich Verantwortung für sich
selbst und wollen ihre Patienten
schützen während der unicronwelle haben
wir aus gutem Grund die kritische
Infrastruktur im Blick und ja auch in
Pflegeheimen infizieren sich derzeit
Beschäftigte und auch das kann die
Versorgungssicherheit beeinträchtigen ja
es trifft auch geimpfte aber diese
erkranken in der Regel nicht so schwer
wie ihre ungeimpften Kolleginnen sie
können die Arbeit schneller wieder
aufnehmen und haben auch ein weitaus
geringeres Risiko für Hospitalisierung
oder eine mögliche longkobit Erkrankung
der ohne Frage bestehende Person
pflegepersonalmangel wird jedenfalls
nicht dadurch gelindert dass wir die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht wieder
zurücknehmen hier braucht es
ambitionierte Maßnahmen solche wie wir
sie im Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart
haben bessere Arbeitsbedingungen
personalbemessungsinstrumente die
greifen und eine wirkliche Offensive für
die Pflegeausbildung z.B durch die
Schaffung von Ausbildungsplätzen auch in
Rehakliniken dabei dürfen wir nicht
übersehen die Bekämpfung des
Fachkräftemangels in der Pflege ist ein
Mammutprojekt hier kann auch die Ampel
nicht mit einem Federstrich ein Problem
lösen dass ich über Jahrzehnte angestaut
hat und eines ist klar den
Herausforderungen in der Pflege begegnet
man nicht indem man seine eigenen kruden
Ideologien bedient sondern indem man die
Komplexität anerkennt und gemeinsam
Lösungen sucht und das unterscheidet uns
von ihnen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
Freien Demokraten haben es uns bei der
Frage der einrichtungsbezogenen
Impfpflicht nicht leicht gemacht uns ist
die Verhältnismäßigkeit der
Schutzmaßnahmen gegenüber den Eingriffen
in die persönliche Freiheit wichtig wir
haben dieser zielgerichteten Maßnahme
zugestimmt eben weil uns der Schutz der
alten und kranken Menschen wichtig ist
die Regelung ist befristet und wird
selbstverständlich evaluiert werden
wir sind froh dass ich die
Gesundheitsministerkonferenz nun auf ein
kluges und abgestuftes Verfahren zur
Umsetzung verständigt hat dabei geht es
auch darum dass nicht geimpfte
übergangsweise weiterbeschäftigt werden
das Betretungsverbot ist die ultima
ratio es bleibt dabei Aufklärung und
niedrigschwellige impfangebote sind die
stärksten Instrumente zur Steigerung der
Impfquote genau diese
sollte Priorität haben damit es zu
betretungsverboten erst gar nicht kommen
muss vielen Dank
vielen Dank
und die nächste Rednerin ist für die
SPD-Fraktion lisa hat baradari
Gesundheitsausschuss
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger seit zwei Jahren
leben wir in Deutschland ja die gesamte
weltengemeinschaft in einer
Ausnahmesituation aus medizinischer
Indikation mussten wir teils große
Einschränkung hinnehmen seit März 2020
befürchten wir uns an dem neuartigen
Coronavirus anzustecken und
möglicherweise auch daran zu erkranken
wir können froh sein dass wir seit einem
Jahr mit dem vorhandenen Impfstoffen
eine evidenzbasierte Sicherheit gegen
schwere corvit 19 Erkrankung haben
bei dem vorliegenden Antrag ja da darf
ruhig geklatscht werden bei dem
vorliegenden Antrag der AFD geht es
darum dass der Paragraph 20A
desinfektionsschutzgesetzes gestrichen
werden soll mit der Begründung die
corona-pandemie mit der Unicorn Welle
hätte ihren Scheitelpunkt erreicht und
eine einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht
wäre somit hinfällig sie würde sogar zur
weiteren personalflucht führen so die
Behauptung der AFD in Deutschland
arbeiten 1,7 millionenfachkräfte in der
Pflege die Impfquote liegt bei diesem
Beschäftigten erfreulicherweise bei 81%
und den Bohnen bei 91%, also besser als
im bundesdurch bundesdeutschen
Durchschnitt
die Impfquote im pflegerischen und dem
medizinischen Bereich sind gut aber sie
reichen bei weitem nicht aus um Virus
Ausbrüche bei den sogenannten
honorarabischen Gruppen sicher zu
verhindern die Konsequenz ist der
Auswahl von Personal durch Krankheit
Isolation oder bestenfalls Quarantäne es
gibt ohnehin schon ein Pflegenotstand
bedingt durch ungünstige
Arbeitsbedingungen schlechtem
Pflegeschlüssel unter Bezahlung und
Fachkräftemangel laut dem Antrag würde
einen Wegfall der Einrichtung
einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht so zu
einer weiteren Zunahme des
Pflegenotstands führen als Ärztin die
auch im Bereich der Pflege gearbeitet
hat sage ich ihnen eins
die Beschäftigten in der Pflege und in
der Medizin sehen in ihrer Tätigkeit
nicht nur einen Beruf sondern eine
Berufung sie kümmern sich
aufopferungsvoll und die ihnen
anvertrauten Menschen und tun alles ja
sie tun alles für ihren Schutz Frau
Kollegin erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage
aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE
ich möchte mich an diese Stelle
stellvertretend zumindestens für meine
Fraktion und alle anderen demokratischen
Fraktionen
auch bei Herrn Söder bei allem
Beschäftigten in der Pflege in der
Medizin in den Einrichtungen der
Behindertenhilfe und auch bei allen
Beschäftigten der kritischen
Infrastruktur ganz herzlich für ihr
Engagement bedanken denn sie haben seit
Beginn der Pandemie großartiges für die
Menschen geleistet und daher verdienen
Sie unseren größten Respekt
seit Jahrzehnten ja seit Jahrzehnten
muss medizinisches Personal für die
Ausübung entsprechend der Tätigkeiten
gegen bestimmte Krankheiten wie
Hepatitis B oder Masern geimpft sein das
ist doch grundsätzlich nichts Neues
übrigens habe unsere europäischen
Nachbarn sogar 2021 schon längst eine
Impfpflicht im Gesundheitswesen
eingeführt z.B Frankreich z.B
Griechenland oder Italien
kann ich nur jedem raten sich bis ins
letzte Detail über die corona-impfung
beraten zu lassen und sich impfen zu
lassen zum Eigenschutz zum Schutz der
ihn anvertrauten Person und gegenüber
ihren Berufskolleginnen und Kollegen von
der AFD werden hier alternative Fakten
und parallele Welten geschaffen um
Misstrauen und Angst zu erzeugen denn
das ist der Brandbeschleuniger in dem
ohnehin vorhandenen Pflegenotstand
des Bundesverfassungsgericht hören sie
gut zu hat doch gezeigt dass gegen eine
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht Zitat
keine durchgreifenden
verfassungsrechtlichen Bedenken
bestünden und wir werden ihn auch ein
zeigen nämlich so ein Antrag von ihm
vollumfänglich ablehnt vielen Dank
das kündigt hier eine so hartbarer dari
für die SPD-Fraktion an ja viele
europäische Länder sie haben hat ja auch
einige genannt haben eine Impfpflicht
für
Gesundheitsberufe allerdings
Großbritannien beispielsweise während
Deutschland hier über die Teile
Impfpflicht debattiert schafft
Großbritannien
die ein Impfpflicht eingesetzt und
umgesetzt nicht für alle Bereiche und
jetzt sollten Mitarbeiter des
staatlichen Gesundheitsdienstes auch
noch geimpft werden doch vor einigen
Tagen hat die Regierung in
Großbritannien diesen Plan gekippt muss
ein bestehendes Problem auch tatsächlich
lösen und die einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht wie sie vorgelegt wurde von
dieser Bundesregierung die wirft einfach
mehr Fragen in der Umsetzung auf als
dass sie Probleme löst und deshalb bin
ich auch unseren bayerischen
Ministerpräsidenten Dr Markus Söder
dankbar dass er diese Debatte noch mal
aufgemacht hat und dass er
ja das Thema ist ja leider das Thema ist
zu ernst und das wissen sie genau so und
hinterher
[Applaus]
und er hat die Debatte aufgemacht und
hat angesprochen was viele hinter
vorgehaltener Hand gesagt haben Landräte
Gesundheitsminister aller Parteien
Einrichtungen einrichtungsvertreter
pflegende Angehörige alle haben sich
gefragt wie sieht es aus in der
rechtlichen Umsetzung welche
Konsequenzen hat es verliere ich meinen
Beruf kann ich so kann ich pflege noch
gewährleisten wie sieht es aus mit der
Rechtssicherheit und der handlungsklage
und deshalb ist es wirklich wichtig dass
Du heute drüber reden denn ich bin immer
auf deshalb dankbar weil wir uns ja als
Gesellschaft fest vorgenommen haben dass
wir auf die Pflege zukünftig hören
werden dass wir genau hinhören werden
was Pflege sagt und da war es schon im
letzten Dezember so dass die Präsidentin
des Deutschen pflegerates gesagt hat
dass sie für eine einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht ist aber eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht muss auf dem Fuße folgen
denn die Bewältigung der Pandemie ist
eine gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe und
keine Einbahnstraße und das
hat auch viele das hat auch viele neue
Kollegen dazu bewogen dieser
einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht
zuzustimmen die protokollerklärungen
liegen vor weil eben der Kanzler Olaf
Scholz gesagt hat die allgemeine
Impfpflicht wird sofort folgen und Fakt
ist sie tut es nicht Frau Kollegin
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage von
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Kölner ich habe ihre Worte gehört und
sie sagen ja sie stehen zur
einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht sie
müsse aber gefolgt werden durch eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht kann ich aus
dieser durchaus nachvollziehbaren Kette
schließen dass sie erstens als Fraktion
der Union dann einen Antrag oder den
gruppenanträgen zur allgemeinen
Impfpflicht zustimmen werden und
zweitens haben sie ja auch zurecht
gerade betont dass wir mit ihren Stimmen
sowohl im Bundesrat als auch hier im
Bundestag die einrichtungsbezogene
Impfung ja für alle Fachkräfte alle
Beschäftigten in diesen Einrichtungen
geschlossen worden ist und schon damals
war klar dass es natürlich Auswirkungen
hat
Weise auf ein Arbeitsverhältnis wo ich
das Arbeitsverhältnis gar nicht mehr
einlösen kann wenn ich die Sicherheit
nicht gewährleisten kann als
Beschäftigter auch tatsächlich
eingesetzt zu werden also diese Fragen
waren ja bekannt von Anfang an haben sie
diese
Implikationen nicht gesehen als sie
zugestimmt haben haben sie das alles
nicht gewusst als sie sogar als CSU sehr
sehr prominent die einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht gefordert haben
[Applaus]
ich persönlich bin gegen eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht und ich bin auch gegen die
einrichtungsbezogene
was ich hier dargestellt habe ist das
eben das Gesetz dass sie vorgelegt haben
dass das einfach handwerklich schlecht
gemacht ist und was ich eingefordert
habe ist
dass sie nein ich habe dem Gesetz nicht
zugestimmt so es ist nämlich nicht nur
in ihrer Partei so dass wir natürlich
Unterschiede haben in den Nuancen
sondern ist es eine gesellschaftliche
gesamtgesellschaftliche Debatte und die
nimmt vor keiner Fraktion vor keiner
Partei Rücksicht aber unabhängig davon
unabhängig davon
dass die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht dass
ich und das ist das was ich auch
formuliert habe dass die Bitte besteht
besser auf die Pflege zu hören und ich
habe nur wiedergegeben was die
pflegevertreter gesagt haben und die
Präsidentin des Deutschen pflegerats hat
eben ganz klar formuliert sie stehen für
eine einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht
aber eine allgemeine Impfpflicht muss
folgen und das liefern sie nicht sonst
hätten wir sie ja schon so und deshalb
ist es finde ich
nein es ist nicht ungeheuerlich liebe
Kollegin Behrens sondern was
ungeheuerlich ist dass sie wissen dass
sie keine Mehrheit haben für eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht aber anstatt
diese vorzulegen und die Anträge wieder
einzukassieren
halten Sie hier das Land in Geiselhaft
und suggerieren dass sie in der Lage
wären eine allgemeine Impfpflicht
durchzusetzen das ist Teil der Wahrheit
200 Stimmen da andere für die Anträge
oder für einen Antrag die Reichen am
Ende des Tages nicht aus sie brauchen
eine Mehrheit und das ist das was wir
von den Regierungsfraktionen auch
erwarten legen Sie etwas vor und dann
können wir uns auch kritisch damit
auseinandersetzen das wäre ihre Aufgabe
gewesen
ich hätte mir ich hätte mir bei der
einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht einen
vorwärtsgewandten Vorschlag gewünscht
die Helden der Pandemie so wird die
Pflege bezeichnet das sind eben nicht
nur die Pflegekräfte die sich impfen
lassen sondern es sind auch die die
ihren Dienst geleistet haben als es noch
keine Impfung gab und erlauben sie noch
eine weitere Zwischenfrage aus der
FDP-Fraktion
hätte ich mir eine ja die FDP brauche
jetzt gar nicht so rumstöhnen sie haben
im Wahlkampf Werbung gegen die
Impfpflicht gemacht ja und jetzt sind
sie komplett alles weggewischt
also bisschen Zurückhaltung
die vorwärtsgewandte Lösung ist der
Paragraph 23 im Infektionsschutzgesetz
und der besagt dass natürlich alles
getan werden muss das Infektionen egal
ob Corona oder MRSA oder weitere Träger
weitere Infektionen werden muss das ist
eben verhindert wird dass es zu einem
Eintrag in die Einrichtungen kommt und
deshalb gibt der Paragraph 23 schon
heute eine vorwärtsgewandte Lösung her
nämlich das Pflegepersonal oder auch
weitere Kräfte die eben eingestellt
werden neu eingestellt werden dass die
einen gewissen Impfschutz ja auch jetzt
wurde bitte zum Schluss
dazu kommen fakt ist aber auch das was
wir jetzt in der Diskussion haben ist
eine rückwärtsgewandte Debatte denn wir
haben in einem Beruf wo es der
mangelberuf ist laufen wir einfach
Gefahr dass weitere Betten auch
tatsächlich geschlossen werden müssen
sammeln sie ihre Anträge ein gehen sie
in Klausur und kommen Sie nach einer
Woche wieder als staatstragende
Fraktionen mit einem Vorschlag danke
schön Frau Kolleginnen danke
[Applaus]
und allgemeiner Impfpflicht die
allgemeine Impfpflicht soll ab März im
Bundestag debattiert werden es liegen
verschiedene Anträge vor es gibt
übrigens wahrscheinlich auch ein nach
bisherigem Stand Antrag von cdu/csu im
Bundestag vor die sich dazu entschieden
haben einen eigenen fraktionsantrag
trotzdem einzubringen der eine
gesetzliche Impfpflicht sozusagen auf
Vorrat vorsieht und die vorzubereiten
also alle Anträge zur allgemeinen
Impfpflicht dann hier im Bundestag im
März heute wurde debattiert auf
Grundlage eines Antrages der
afd-fraktion über die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht die ist
eigentlich schon Sache es wurde mir mal
angesprochen im Dezember haben Bundestag
und Bundesrat diese einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht beschlossen und mit Mehrheit
abgestimmt auch aus Bayern wo es ja von
Bayerns Ministerpräsident Kritik gab
jetzt letztens und er angekündigt hatte
nicht umsetzen will gab es gestern
andere Signale Bayern stehen für
Personal von Gesundheits- und
Pflegeeinrichtungen
der bayerischen Staat verliere und auch
Bund und Länder haben sich gestern in
ihrer corona-lage dazu noch einmal
ich lasse nun abstimmen über den
überweisungsvorschlag der Fraktion SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP also
Federführung beim Ausschuss für
Gesundheit wer stimmt für diesen
überweisungsvorschlag das ist DIE LINKE
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen FDP und
cdu/csu wer stimmt dagegen das ist die
AFD Enthaltung keine dieser
überweisungsvorschlag ist angenommen
also der afd-antrag sie haben nichts
verpasse ist ja nicht abgestimmt worden
heute sondern er geht zur weiteren
Beratungen in die Ausschüsse und zwar
allerdings strittig zwischen den
Fraktionen welcher der fischführende für
die Beratung sein soll und das ist jetzt
hier beschlossen worden mit der Mehrheit
des Hauses gegen die Stimmen der AFD der
Gesundheitsausschuss wird über diesen
Antrag also
parlamentarisch beraten